a lot of what you're seeing
as attacks on me quite frankly are
attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
that was dr anthony fauci going after
his critics referring to himself in the
third person
as he claims he has always simply
followed the science but critics point
to fouching his
fauci's history of flip-flopping on key
issues during the pandemic
for example his guidance on wearing
masks
right now in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks there's no reason to be
walking around with a mask i think what
people
don't fully appreciate is that putting a
mask
on yourself is more to
prevent you from infecting someone else
and if everybody does that we're each
protecting each other the accumulation
of all of those scientific
facts information and evidence brought
the cdc to make that decision to say
now when you're vaccinated you don't
need to wear a mask
not only outdoors but you don't need to
wear it indoors
and don't forget his evolving opinion on
the origins of covet 19.
if you look at the genomic sequences
of the viruses that are in bats in the
wild
it's strikingly similar to the sequences
that you have found now in people who
have been infected with the original
wild-type
virus are you still confident that it
developed naturally
no actually no i'm not convinced uh
about that i think that we should
continue to investigate
what went on in china until we find out
to the best of our ability
exactly what happened
oh kaylee the star of the fouchy show
strikes again
oh yes indeed as arizona columnist john
gabriel put it and the science became
flesh and dwelt among us
of course in the form of saint anthony
fauci who now says
i am science who now says i am truth
well let's talk about that truth you
pointed out too the masked
situation he was wrong on the wuhan lab
situation he was wrong on
he was also wrong to tell president
trump not to ban travel from china
president trump did it anyway he was
wrong to say asymptomatic spread would
not be a driver of this
uh he was wrong on so many counts there
were many more i could go through like
saying we wouldn't have a vaccine and
be fully back to normal until 2022 and
we saw dr fauci and the white house be
wrong
time and time again and we would look
around at one another and say this guy's
up for time man of the year instead of
our health care workers
this guy's on in style magazine this
guy's doing facebook lives he's not
putting in the work
but he is emailing about how he looks
like brad pitt it is just
remarkable and i'm glad he's being held
to account
i mean i don't know if he'll consider
this attacking him but no he does not
look
like brad pitt and ben this is against
the backdrop too we now know from
adam andershevsky of open the books this
is the highest paid employee in the
federal government
courtesy of our tax dollars yeah more
than anyone else
and if you look at dr fauci and just
look at it from a basic doctor
perspective
i have two family members that have been
dealing with cancer and when you find
out that you have cancer what do you do
you start trying to find the best doctor
you can find if you're looking at dr
fauci's resume from an individual
standpoint here
of is he protecting me the answer is
clearly no
he lied about hydroxychloroquine and its
effectiveness he lied about the origins
i would argue now
of where this came from and put out
communist propaganda from china
this is a guy that lied about mass he
lied about the schools and could kids go
back to school or not
he's gotten virtually everything wrong
when it comes to our national decision
making
on mandates on lockdowns on schooling
so why on earth would anyone trust him
and he's not a political guy
this job's not supposed to be a
political guy this guy is more
partisan when it comes to the decision
making that he made clearly against
donald trump and loving
you know joe biden and now he's trying
to hide behind
it's not me it's science you're the
doctor that got it all wrong and you
didn't look at the science and you
didn't trust the science
on any of it and now i'm sorry i don't
think science should save your job
i think he should be fired not because
i'm it's personal it's because he's a
terrible doctor for the american people
and ben our prayers are with both of
your loved ones for full and speedy
recoveries
leslie what are your thoughts on this
well i have many uh and i know you all
hate when i say i'm married to a
physician
but here's one of the things that
doctors have
issues with with we the non-doctors are
the patients
they're not gods and they don't always
know all the answers
there are a lot of theories hypotheses
things that aren't proven
and things that are fluid now certainly
with kova that was the case
not just for fouchy but for the entire
international medical community
as more information came in he would
give that information
he would refer to the cdc uh let me let
me just say this
eggs we were told eggs were good for you
then we were told eggs were bad for us
then we were told just eat the whites
now the yellow is good too the yolk is
good too
do we fire or all the cardiologists i
don't think dr fauci should be fired
because
medicine research technology viruses
like coed
are ecovid are ever changing they are
fluid and doctors
answers to our questions will be as well
they're not gods they're people who
study
medicine and science interestingly that
egg analogy actually had to do in part
with the lobbying
influence and certain special interest
groups having
impact on how things are marketed to the
american people which harris
i actually think fits here too
so i loved ben's example if you
are sick and you go to one doctor and
you
have questions about what that doctor
has told you you get
a second opinion we didn't have that
option as the american people
we were dying we were getting sick
people that i love
people that you love and i know maybe it
wasn't equal across the country
everybody had a different example or
experience but we're all americans and
we were losing
and it hurt and this was a person who
stood up who
undoubtedly has worn a mask before this
pandemic because he's a doctor i'm sure
he's been around sick patients
and knows the efficacy of mask wearing
understands it so if he's giving out
muddled information and now that muddled
information
gave time to our enemies to vacuum up
ppe around the world
whether he meant it or not he wasn't
good at his job
but we weren't in a position to get a
second opinion
now we are and we're still not out of
this yet
we're trying to help other countries
we're trying to help ourselves we're
going forward
and because of operation warp speed
and because of the medical professionals
who are incredible
with their time and their passion and
their love for their patients around our
nation during a pandemic because of
those heroes
we're still standing and we'll go forth
i don't know
is it about you don't like dr fauci or
you don't like the job he's doing
either way we have the right to a second
opinion
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now